hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2021 british science fiction movie
called settlers
the movie begins with a small family who
lives in an outpost on mars because
earth is no longer habitable the
nine-year-old daughter remy is seen
observing constellations in the sky as
her father and her mother ilsa
accompanies her living with no neighbors
no resources and no communication nearby
the family has to grow their own
vegetables and raise the one and only
pig in order to survive
curious about the outside world remy
attempts to explore the land but ilsa
forbids her to move any further the dad
returns home but with a worried face as
something is happening outside remy
realizes that there are strangers nearby
but the father convinces her to stay
calm
that night she can't sleep and decides
to sleep with her parents despite living
alone on an uninhabited planet they
enjoy their quality time as a family
where the father states that they're
very lucky to be given an opportunity to
live in such a place believing that
someday mars will be just like earth the
next day remy awakens in his shock when
she discovers a threatening note written
on their kitchen window telling them to
leave the house
not long after elsa shows up with her
father who is already equipped with a
rifle he looks all around but cannot
find anybody it seems like the parents
are aware that they don't live alone
there he screams at the window
challenging the invaders to show up and
fight him
worried about her the one and only pig
remy quietly walks toward the barn
suddenly two invaders appear trying to
kidnap the daughter but the father
manages to shoot down one of them and
elsa stabs the other one with a knife
she brings remy with her and they take
shelter in the house while the father
hides behind the house's wall trying to
eliminate the last invader who is
shooting from a distance
ilsa helps the father locating the foe
and he manages to shoot him down
even though it's going to be dark soon
the father reloads his weapon and leaves
the house to eliminate the remaining
invaders leaving remy and elsa in fear
they lock all the doors and hide in a
room while waiting for the father to
return home
not long after they hear someone
approaching the house and suddenly all
the main lights are shut down
they have to spend the entire night in
fear
the following morning ilsa equipped
herself with a knife walks out from the
hideout
suddenly a man who introduces himself as
jerry appears and threatens to shoot
ilsa if she does not comply turns out
that he is the man who was shot by the
father on the hill but not killed since
the bullet hit the leg
he reveals that the house belongs to his
parents and his only intention is just
only to reclaim his rightful home
jerry offers them to stay promising that
he will protect ilsa and her daughter or
they can just leave without being hurt
she brings her daughter out of the house
to discuss with her despite remy begging
in tears to ilsa to leave the mother
explains that they will not survive in
the outside world
seeing jerry on the hill ilsa sneaks
into the house grabs a knife and
attempts to kill him however he figures
out the movement and manages to prevent
her from killing him
jerry makes a deal with her if ilsa can
behave in the next 30 days for him to
prove himself he will hand over the gun
to her and give her the chance to kill
him
leaving with no option ilsa has to
accept the deal
after that jerry grants her request to
bury the father who was killed by jerry
during the gunfight the previous night
remy begins the 30 days countdown by
drawing a bar on the window every day
ilsa and remy slowly manage to accept
reality and live with the existing
situation
one day the daughter climbs up on a
container and secretly peeks at jerry
through the skylight discovering a
hidden underground storage where he
keeps all his weapons she then comes
across his belongings finding a gas mask
and a drawing of a woman who was killed
during the fight jerry manages to get
the house back on its feet fixing the
broken pipeline so that the water can
flow again the next day elsa finds a
robot in the garage
it seems that the robot likes remy and
they eventually become friends
she even names the robot steve
steve manages to cheer her up in her
gloomy time while elsa slowly builds a
relationship with his husband's killer
as they get closer elsa reveals that
they were initially welcomed by jerry's
parents to live there when they arrived
at mars
however after figuring out that the
family was from earth jerry's dad
attempts to shoot them that's why they
had to kill him and decided to occupy
the house
luckily jerry doesn't hold any grudges
since he hates his parents
the next day jerry approaches remy
allowing her to keep the drawing she
took away earlier as time goes by remy
is speechless when she sees her mother
slowly opens herself up to jerry
the two eventually kiss in the net house
the daughter spots them and becomes very
disappointed thinking how her mom
manages to share a kiss with her
father's killer
in her grief she packs up and attempts
to flee from the house alone without a
map she randomly explores mars
suddenly steve shows up but she drives
it away while yelling her disappointment
towards her mother
after a long walk she comes across a
transparent barrier realizing that she
has been living under the protection of
an invisible wall and there is no way to
leave this place
a few moments later she spots a huge
door hoping that it will bring her to
the other side of the place remy presses
on a button to open the door
she advances into the dark cave as she
hears ilsa calling her from a distance
but she ignores her the cave's door
shuts by itself leaving himself in a
gloomy cave without any help as she
walks through the cave suddenly the door
from the other side of the place opens
frightened she tries to crawl back in
faints
she eventually finds herself in the
house as she awakens
turns out that she was rescued by jerry
who reveals that there is nothing
outside the barrier he tells her that
she must be grateful to live in such a
place
that night elsa tries to comfort remy
convincing her daughter that she loves
her very much
the next day they gather in a room where
ilsa plays the guitar besides jerry
remy recalls her old memories when they
used to play guitar together with her
father
she becomes emotional and runs away from
the house and tears
she is furious with her mother thinking
that she has moved on from her husband
finally the 30 days are up as promised
jerry puts the gun on the table offering
her to kill him if she wants ilsa grabs
the gun pulls the trigger and attempts
to shoot him down
however the gun is empty
realizing that this is just a test and
jerry wants her to live with him she
runs back to the house and tries to
commit suicide
jerry rushes in to stop her but he's too
late he comes out from the house covered
in blood and wounds which makes remy
realize that her mother has died as she
tries to escape he manages to outrun her
and catches her trying to calm her down
and begging her to stay which she
reluctantly agrees to since she has no
other option
filled with hatred toward jerry she
tries to keep her distance from him as
time goes by remy has eventually grown
into a beautiful young woman and the
pigs somehow managed to breed
she even learns how to shoot as now they
have abundant resources jerry informs
riemi that he is going to the valley the
following day and asks her permission to
bring steve with him
feeling uncomfortable without his
companion she decides to follow him to
the valley where jerry is enjoying his
time in a small lake before he goes away
he tells the girl to jump into the lake
filled with curiosity she eventually
dives into the lake
back at home jerry presents remy a
drawing of her deceased mother she
becomes emotional as soon as she sees
the portrait jerry attempts to calm her
down by kissing her but she is shocked
and immediately runs away
she locks herself in her room and he
leaves the drawing at the door
the next day remy secretly plans to flee
to the outside world
at the dinner jerry states his intention
to continue building a romantic
relationship with remy but she rejects
him and will not accept him forever in
her life
the man urges that the action must be
done for the future of mankind but she
doesn't care
later that night steve shows up to cheer
her up and wants to play with her but
she prefers to be alone jerry discovers
remy's plan to leave the place and
becomes furious stating that she won't
last for a day outside there they engage
in a fight and jerry knocks her
unconscious
remy then wakes up finding herself tied
up in the bed
she tries to resist and tries to break
free but her effort is useless he rides
on her and attempts to do a sexual
intercourse with her claiming that it is
to keep the existence of humans luckily
a wild steve appears and shoots jerry in
the throat
filled with anger he chases after the
robot and destroys it this opportunity
gives remy enough time to break free
she equips herself with a rifle and
approaches the dying jerry
fed up with all his [ __ ] she shoots
her to death
since then remy lives alone in the house
slowly becoming frustrated because of
her loneliness
realizing that she is going crazy and
needs company she tries to fix steve and
prepares herself to explore the outside
world by herself
before leaving she leaves steve behind
ordering it to take care of the house
while she is away
wearing the mask she once again visits
the cave and this time manages to reach
its exit door discovering a land
entirely filled with sand and dust
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching